HOLLYWOOD POLICE DEPARTMENT IF
YOU HAVE ANY INFORMATION.
>> WE WILL STAY HERE AS LONG AS
IT TAKES TO GET AN AGREEMENT.
AND WE URGE MR. MEADOWS TO SIT
DOWN AND CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
US TO DO IT AS LONG AS IT TAKES.
>> BY FRIDAY IF WE HAVEN’T MADE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS AND WE’RE
JUST TOO FAR APART, THE
PRESIDENT IS PREPARED TO TAKE
EXECUTIVE ACTION.
>> Sandra: NO DEAL YET ON THE
NEXT CORONAVIRUS RELEASE BILL.
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS STILL
NEGOTIATING ON CAPITOL HILL.
MARK MEADOWS SAYS IF AN
AGREEMENT IS NOT REACHED BY
TOMORROW IT IS DOUBTFUL THERE
WILL BE ANY DEAL AT ALL.
CHAD PERGRAM IS LIVE ON CAPITOL
HILL.
>> THEY’RE TRILLIONS APART HERE.
THE NEGOTIATIONS HAVE GONE ON
FOR DAYS.
THE ONLY PLACE A MOVEMENT IS ON
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE.
THEY’RE A LITTLE BIT CLOSER
THERE.
THE LENGTH OF THESE TALKS,
THAT’S WHAT IS FRUSTRATING MARK
MEADOWS.
>> I CAN JUST TELL YOU THAT
THERE ARE NO TOP LINE NUMBERS
THAT HAVE BEEN AGREED TO.
WE CONTINUE TO BE TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS APART IN TERMS OF WHAT
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
HOPEFULLY WILL ULTIMATELY
COMPROMISE ON.
>> THIS IS THE THICKET OF
NEGOTIATIONS WITH DOZENS OF
THORNY ISSUES.
THEY ARE NOWHERE CLOSE ON FOOD
ASSISTANCE, NOT CLOSE ON SCHOOL
AID.
ALL THEY’VE ACCOMPLISHED IS
NARROWED THE LIST OF ISSUES
WHERE THEY THINK THERE CAN BE
AN AGREEMENT.
HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI
CALLED IT AN UNUSUAL
NEGOTIATION.
>> I FEEL OPTIMISTIC THAT THERE
IS A LIGHT AT THE END OF THE
TUNNEL BUT HOW LONG THAT TUNNEL
IS REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
>> THIS IS WHERE IF THERE IS NO
DEAL THEY COULD TAKE EXECUTIVE
ACTION OVER THE WEEKEND OR NEXT
WEEK WHERE THE PRESIDENT HAS
TALKED MAYBE SANDRA ABOUT A
MORATORIUM ON EVICTIONS AND
SUSPENDING THE COLLECTION OF
PAYROLL TAXES.
>> Sandra: WHY DO THEY THINK
THEY CAN GET A DEAL DONE NOW
AFTER TWO WEEKS OF NEGOTIATIONS?
>> THEY DON’T.
THAT’S WHAT IS SO INTERESTING
ABOUT THIS.
THIS WAS SUMMED UP BY MEADOWS
YESTERDAY AFTERNOON.
LISTEN.
>> THIS IS NOT A FINE WINE THAT
DON’T IMPROVE WITH TIME.
>> THE SENATE HASN’T TRIED TO
ADVANCE AN INTERIM PLAN ON
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE DESPITE
SUGGESTIONS THAT WOULD HAPPEN
THIS WEEK.
FOX IS TOLD ANY MEASURE MY ONLY
COMMAND 40GOP VOTES.
IF THERE IS NOT AN AGREEMENT
FOX IS TOLD THE ADMINISTRATION
COULD TRY TO USE SOME UNUSED
CORONAVIRUS MONEY FROM OLD
BILLS BACK IN MARCH.
ALSO MONEY FROM THE DISASTER
RELIEF FUND IF THEY CAN’T GET